first of all I think we mentioned this
in the lesson before the lesson I think
the previous lesson we ask Allah Asel to
Grant relief to our Muslim brothers and
sisters in Palestine and elsewhere uh we
feel for them and we know that they are
being oppressed and we ask allel to to
grant them the greatest of Rewards uh
for those who have been killed obviously
it's it's martyrdom to be buried under
Rubble or to have a building destroyed
upon you so we ask Allah that he accepts
and he makes them uh to be martyrs that
the children amongst them obviously they
will go into Paradise risk Allah to get
to give them a tremendous uh reward for
the patience now when it comes to
speaking about this issue we have to be
very very careful because as we said
before there are many many people who
speak on the basis of emotion it's a
very emotive
issue and these These are the types of
fitan where people they will end up
being
drowned
because
they they can't tame their
emotions through sound authentic
knowledge and sound Islamic principles
right the ability to re in your emotions
and to control your
emotions this is what
distinguishes a strong person a person
of firm resolution of firm will compared
to the people who are just like
effectively just you know uh really they
just like this is a sign of their
weakness right that you become overtaken
by by rage and by emotion it means that
really you do not have
conviction
conviction in what Allah has informed us
in the Quran right it's a sign of
weakness and a sign of lack of
conviction in Allah's promise that it is
true and so we have to be careful there
are many many people on social media and
elsewhere they like to use this issue as
I said the issue of Palestine or it
could be any other Calamity and they
have ideological motives they have
reasons to attack salais in particular
why
because
because because of our
conviction in the
truth of what the messenger of Allah
what he
brought
regarding these types of calamities
these types of events why they happen
what the reason is you know like in in
detail how to deal with it how to
resolve it right I want to give you just
a very quick uh example of this to show
how these things have happened in
history in the time of
Islam you know the Mongols attacked from
the East and there were things that
happened that were much
worse than what we are seeing today in
Palestine because when the Mongols came
uh from the direction of the East they
passed through
Bagdad and in
bdad there were this is Haku right and
and you know and uh some of the rafida
evil rafida they basically played a role
in in directing the Mongols in deceiving
the the ruler of
Bagdad um in into you know giving up or
whatever right so they so they aided the
mongal against the the Sunni Muslims in
any case when they came they slaughtered
as you know the story they sucked the
whole of bagd
the the the city was was flowing in
blood the killed I don't know how many
mil you know tremendous Butchery in
Massacre and then they were coming
across and then they came toward Sham in
the time
ofl there the people of knowledge the
scholars they actually differed with
each other some Scholars said you know
what we have to go out we must do Jihad
in the path of Allah we have to fight
them we have to stop them we have to
repel them you know whatever whatever
other Scholars said you know what this
really isn't the time to be doing that
now imagine a situation now right
there's a invading Army coming from the
East ravaging everything right
destroying everybody massacring whatever
and you hear some Scholars saying no no
no we this is not the time like what
would you imagine would be said about
those
Scholars right I'm trying to give you
this I'm giving this example to show
you
that the difference
between uh being rooted in
knowledge and then while being rooted in
knowledge making anad that might be
right or
wrong and between just reacting with
emotion right so in this situation
explains this in one of his
books right and he says that this this
dispute happened between the people of
knowledge so what happened is he
basically
advised that if we look at the H of the
people what do we see the people when
they heard the Mongols coming from the
East the first thing they started doing
was running out started running out
going to the graves seeking refuge in
the graves you know saying in poetry
that the T have come you know we seek
refuge in you oh ABA Omar you know
they're like making these you know and
this is what the people were upon and so
the scholars like who were deeply
grounded and rooted and they
said if this is the situation of the
people then it's unlikely that the Jihad
that we fight against the Mongols is
going to be successful so we shouldn't
really do
it so says for the next
years we embarked upon educating the
people to invoke only Allah alone right
to make the wle upon Allah so they so
they went out and they had to teach the
people the Affairs of toed and to make
toed rooted in because before it wasn't
rooted in their hearts to make toed
rooted in their hearts right so when
this
happened and the the affair of the
people was rectified intim says that
there was was such victories against the
tartars against the Mongols that the
Muslims had never ever seen before they
were victorious over the over the over
the Mongols
now
this situation I'm sure has happened
many times in history where there where
there are difference differences of
opinion now can you imagine someone
coming along and saying saying about
those Scholars who said
this is not the time for fighting right
imagine someone saying you are from thef
you you you are from the Y you are from
the this you from that whatever this
would be a stupid evil
misguided ignorant fool who would be
making remarks like this you would you
wouldn't make remarks like this it shows
your complete lack of comprehension of
the religion to be even making remarks
like that right now if we now come and
we we are honest
with
ourselves honest with
ourselves right so again this is not for
the for the
effeminate men who are overtaken by
emotion that we see amongst these people
of B this is not for you so you you
leave the arena and leave it for the men
to discuss the actual issues right so we
know in in the Sunnah as the M messenger
said someone came and said oh messenger
of Allah
a man fights for bravery a man fights
for tribal nationalism the man fights
for
booty who is the one fighting for the
sake of
Allah and so the messenger said the one
who fights so that the word of Allah is
uppermost he is the one who is
fighting right
and in the is
qualified
by is qualified by that what does that
mean to make the word of Allah uppermost
okay that's the Jihad that Allah Allah
he gives Victory to that he AIDs that he
supports why why because the point of
dispute is the
that's the point of dispute right
now if you like coming back to the
Hadith the one who fights for like the
one who fights for tribal nationalism
partisanship right if you are going to
fight for
nationalism for a
nation then there's no difference
between you and between any other Nation
and that's what the scholars have
explained that if you fight and they
refute when when the scholars when they
refute the scholars spoke about
this and many other Scholars that this
evil filth has come to us from the
direction of the enemies right they have
put this you know through through
certain rulers like Saddam Hussein and
you know Jamal Abdul Naser and others
they infused this idea of Arabic
nationalism in order to weak weaken the
the the Muslim nations
right and so there's this nationalism
there's other things that have come
which have weakened the Muslim if you
fight on the basis of nationalism then
you you you will be ruined and you will
be lost and you'll be destroyed and now
there's no difference between you and
between any other non-muslim Nation
who's also fighting for nationalism
right you want a state they want a state
right this this is nationalism now okay
right what do you find amongst those
people who are fighting
right the head of you know from these
heads of of Hamas and we are speaking
here in terms of what their Creed is
what the methodology is you will find
statements from them saying in the '90s
you know earlier on or in two sorry 2000
yeah saying for example yes we we are
fighting because we we are trying to
establish uh democracy and equal rights
for everybody and these are their
words actual
words
right right and you have Communists you
have secularists you have marxists
actual groups of actual marxists of
actual Communists who who are
Palestinians there
right now let's be honest with
ourselves is this something that Allah
is going to Aid in the way that he
aided the Russ n
Alam ibraim alisam
mam Muhammad s wasallam right what is
being fought for what's at stake what's
the
dispute right and what what are you
after you after you after Homeland are
you after what is it these are
questions that as I said the people of
the Sunnah are able to raise these
questions because these are what the
Theo and the foundations from the
religion that they know
are the truth and they know how Allah's
Aid is obtained
right
so so so so this is just one one angle
this is just one angle of looking at the
whole situation right if you're going to
fight for nationalism then you know this
does not mean in any way form or
fashion that somehow now we do not
support our Muslim brothers and sisters
right only an idiot a fool a liar
aab an enous one who hates the people of
the Sunnah and the truth that they speak
would ever reason like that do you
understand like just because we've
pointed out the
truth that Allah only AIDs that which is
which is not for fought for not for
whatever right only that is what is
aided by Allah that when we point that
out and we try to
make clear what is obvious that if you
fight for nationalism then this is not
going to win the aid and support of
Allah right only a fool and an idiot
from the people of bid is going to use
that now and say oh you are hypocrites
because now you support the you know the
the the the the oppressing party no it's
that doesn't follow we are trying to
analyze and truthfully find the the the
right solution to the problem in
accordance with with with the rules of
Allah in his creation and what Allah has
mentioned in his book and what the
scholars we know from experience like I
gave the example of in his time right
that that this is how you analyze these
situations right so this in no way means
that we do not
support the the the our brothers and
sisters uh who are who are who are who
are being oppressed and occupied and
bombed and and and murdered and and you
know whatever of course not but we have
to be honest we have to be honest you
know uh in in in treating the the the
the the situation it's like if a
physician came and you know uh instead
of doing what actually needs to be done
upon the proper analysis he just tried
to comfort and give emotional you know
to the to the subject and just ignore
the re how how is he going to cure
anything or treat it's not going to make
any sense so in the same way
uh you have to treat these situations in
the same way like as a as a based upon
the the the principles and the rules
that that's just one thing anyway that's
the first thing
anyway the second thing is just pure
Common Sense pure reason like our
Scholars have explained before like
Alani from 20 30 years ago he said what
is the benefit of you going and doing
attacking a bus or two buses killing one
or two people whatever and then they
come along and they bombard and they
take 10 20
100 even a thousand where's the where's
the benefit in this of what benefit is
this to anybody what what are you doing
apart from just enabling the the uh
confiscation of more and more land and
the increased militarization where's the
benefit in this if you make any sense
you understand right so again putting
emotions to one side ask yourself one
thing what's what was the benefit of
October 7th what was the benefit in that
tell us
now put all emotions to one side right
what is the benefit what was the benefit
now half of Gaza is now militarily
occupied half of it a million and so
many people are now pushed to the South
so what was the benefit in that then
give it another week two weeks three
weeks whatever and maybe they'll take
you know the whole of it whatever what
what was the benefit in that
then and the strangest thing
is these
other people like we are concerned for
the blood and the
land of the Palestinians when we say
what we say
genuinely and the realities support what
we
say right look at the
outcome right the strangest thing is
these people these people who hate the
people of the Sunnah they have to be
complete they have they have to be
deranged we don't know what it is with
these people they have to be deranged to
somehow
accuse us of saying well you you you are
with the zionists and you are with you
aref you are hypocrites you this how can
you even say that doesn't even make any
sense just because we don't support the
actions of Hamas doesn't mean that we
not with and our sentiments are not with
the people of Palestine
no this is great Injustice in fact this
is just called calculated lies that you
are telling against the people of the
Sunnah who are more knowledgeable than
you they are wiser than you they are
they are greater they are more masculine
than you right cuz you are just
effeminate you you're just emotion
filled effeminate you know I don't want
to use the the words but this is not for
you to speak in you just go away and
just you know whatever don't speak about
this it's not for you to speak about
this clearly you you're not qualified to
speak about
this right so this is so this is now a
second dimension to it right which is
just ground realities practicalities
which the scholars have already spoken
with and which these people don't accept
from us right which is what's the
benefit in doing
that when you've just lost half the land
you know that that you were living on
and you've displaced over a million
people you've destroyed so many people's
lives so many people's children have
been killed you know 10 15,000 what was
the benefit in that
then there is no benefit
right so that's that's the second thing
I mean many many things can be said to
be honest with you but you know
inshallah uh these fitan are going to
increase these tribulations are going to
increase
anyone
who is firmly rooted in
knowledge and takes learning
seriously he will be protected from
being tossed and pushed in every
direction whenever any new comes right
this is just the start of the F there
more as you know there's no time from
the of anbin Malik there's no time
except that the time which will come
after it will be worse than it and the
tribulations come successively they will
come in a way that you know as soon as
one's dropped the next one's going to
drop right this is just this is
tribulation right tribulation they they
fabricated the whole pandemic covid
right this tribulation destroyed the
world's economy you know ruined people's
livelihoods whatever uh straight on the
back of that another tribulation a
another
tribul it's on and on and on and on
right it's like that and so someone who
is not rooted
in actual AA right he will be tossed and
turned in every direction that's why
that's why these people B who are
attacking us they have no knowledge of
you could look what what do they talk
about nothing in terms of like the
actual ual religion nothing they don't
teach it they don't speak about it right
they don't value it and they the most
confused and misguided in their
positions they have the most enmity and
hatred towards the people of and the
sunah who speak with wisdom who speak
with wisdom who speak to to care
genuinely for the for for for the lives
of the Muslims and the welfare of the
Muslim of the next you see they are the
most they are the ones going to be swept
away in the fitan and surprisingly we
wouldn't be surprised if they are the
ones going to end up following theal
when he comes right as we know about ra
will follow him the will be in his midst
as we see in authentic Hadith and the
yah are going to be with him as well
some not all right because that Hadith
as Scholars explained it's not all the
yeh some some of the yeh and those that
remain after is Alam kills him they will
become they will become Muslim right
it's not all the yahood
so uh these are the types of people were
going to be put into tribulation why
because they are speaking without
knowledge without grounding in toed
without understanding and knowing the
rules of Allah and his creation and um
you know speak with Jal so we have to be
careful not to engage with these types
of people um we have we have enough to
be involved in in relation to ourselves
our families every man be concerned with
himself um and and you know save himself
and his
family um but this is very dangerous to
speak to speak in these issues without
knowledge and they're going like I said
is slowly going to be a separation
between those who are grounded upon
sound authentic knowledge in which
there's no role for emotion and
sentiments and between those who are
just given to their how and their
emotions and their feelings and their
rage and their anger right and it's
going to be like divide like this and
the fit are going to come the
tribulation is going to come one group
is going to be more and more cemented
and the other people are just going to
perish and go into ruin and and the
dividing line is sound authentic
knowledge sound Creed sound methodology
that's what the determining thing is so
we shouldn't feel you know just because
all these these people are barking like
dogs as the shik mentioned in his
lecture so we find some of them they
bark like dogs at you let them bark like
dogs ignore
them right so that's that's what I can
say in brief there's a lot more to be
said but inshah that's that's what I
what I can say on the topic very very
briefly and Allah knows
best Allah Knows
Best